I define a function "move" with an input
distribution p and a motion number "U,"
where U is the number of grid cells that the
robot is moving to the right or to the left
I want you to program a function that
returns the new distribution Q after the move
where if U equals zero, Q is the same as p.
If U equals 1, all the values are cyclically
shifted to the right by 1.
If U equals 3, they are cyclically shifted to the right by 3.
If U equals -1, they're cyclically shifted to the left.
Please call the function with argument p
and a shift to the right by 1.
I've commented out my measurement part
because for now
I don't want to do measurement updates.
In addition to this, I will use a very simple p,
that has a 1 at the second position and zeros elsewhere.
Otherwise, if we were to use the uniform p,
we couldn't even see the effect of the motion
whether that's programmed correctly or not.